c'était jour de rentrée scolaire au
liberia où les écoles ont été fermées
pendant sept mois à cause de l'ebola qui
a fait tout près de 10000 morts en
afrique de l'ouest il ya maintenant un
an qu a officiellement commencé
l'épidémie qui a mis à rude épreuve en
c'est la capacité de réagir des
différents gouvernements et organismes
on vous propose donc un bilan d'étape
michel bonsoir bonsoir celui là un an
plus tard est-ce qu'on est proche la de
la fin de cette épidémie bon utilisons
le terme optimisme prudent
les choses vont beaucoup mieux que l'an
dernier regardons les chiffres ensemble
pour l'ensemble de l'épidémie alors si
on regarde les trois pays guinée liberia
sierra leone on a vu l'an passé que
l'épidémie a vraiment pris son envol
septembre octobre novembre et en
novembre on avait jusqu'à 600 nouveaux
cas par semaine et après noël voilà que
tout chute
on se retrouve actuellement avec une
centaine de nouveaux cas par semaine
peut-être que ce serait bien de faire le
bilan vraiment examiner ce qu'on en est
exactement
alors si on regarde les lieux regarde
les chiffres guinée 3190 cas sierra
leone 11370 se libérer à 2265 n oublions
pas qu ailleurs dans le monde il ya eu
de petits foyers à 35 ans pour un total
de 23 1860 la bonne nouvelle c'est
l'insee qu'au liberia depuis une semaine
il n'y a aucun nouveau cas et on a vu
ces images
quand allons-nous pouvoir déclarer
victoire véritable bon voilà ça prend ça
prend beaucoup de jours ça prend 40 du
jour en fait sans qu'il n'y a aucun
nouveau cas dans un pays pour que l'on
puisse déclarer se pile l'hébreu niveau
là alors ce n'est pas avant selon les
autorités l'été où on pourra
probablement dire que l'épidémie se
termine
qu'est-ce que des bonnes nouvelles du
côté des traitements des médicaments des
vaccins alors on en a beaucoup parlé
s'attarde on commence à peine sur le
terrain a démarré les choses il n'y a
qu'un seul le médicament le fai veepee
ravir pour lesquelles on a certains
résultats préliminaires
donc ce médicament japonais là si on
l'utilisé chez les gens qui ont des
débuts de symptômes on voit une
amélioration de 50 % 2
k mais c'est une toute petite corps de
quarante personnes donc les chercheurs
sont pris dans et l'organisation
mondiale de la santé est également
prudente elle dit de ne pas distribuer
ça pour l'instant tout démarre les imap
démarré vendredi dernier
bon alors donnez nous un peu de
nouvelles de ces pays là sur le terrain
ça se passe parce qu'ils ont été très
touchés c'est effectivement très très
très touché je crois que tout le monde a
appris de la leçon principale c'est
d'intervenir rapidement
on l'a pas fait donc on a beaucoup tardé
hélas ce que l'on apprend c'est que ces
pays ont mis tous ont fait leurs efforts
à tenter de contenir ebola et pendant ce
temps là il ya d'autres maladies céline
qui sont encore plus grave je pense à la
tuberculose ou à la malaria ou on n'a
pas mis suffisamment d'efforts dans ces
pays là donc il va falloir penser à
cette période post ebola le redonner des
moyens sanitaires et économiques pour
redémarrer de ses piles
oui ça c'est sans parler bien sûr la
panique qui s'est emparée lewyllie
occidentaux on pourra en reparler
effectivement façon merci céline